maybe this talk is a little bit of an
anomaly or a shift from some of the
other talks that have been in the
workshop that Alex asked me to speak
about our experiences using deep nuts in
a feedback loop for a real control
system and that's really been our
interest and the interest of my research
group really since its inception we've
been interested in safety safety and
control and how you design mathematical
and computational tools to verify safety
of a particular control system and we've
been working historically on safety
critical control systems like air
traffic control systems flight control
systems and and in this problem as
you'll see we'll be focusing on on
navigation using perception in the
feedback loop okay
[Music]
[Music]
just to give you a little bit of a
perspective we've done one experiment
that we've done so we have a robotics
lab refined quadrotors
deductr II in the lab and we computed
we don't really need the audio okay so
um one of the tools that we've been
developing in my group for a long time
is that of reach ability and reachable
sets and the idea is really quite
intuitive suppose you have a system a
dynamic system like a quadrotor flying
and you have a dynamic model of that
system and you also let's start by
assuming that you know the environment
that the system is flying in then you
can use those dynamics and you can use a
model of the environment to basically
compute under different control actions
and with respect to disturbances which
may act on the system what the like a
preview of what's going to happen with
those dynamics by computing a forward
reachable set or you could ask are you
going to ever reach unsafe conditions by
characterizing those conditions as a set
in the state space of the system and
computing a backwards reachable set
using those that dynamic model so we've
been doing a lot of work in my group on
numerical first of all mathematical and
the numerical methods to compute these
using optimal control in differential
games we saw the hamilton-jacobi Isaac's
equation and we compute level set so we
compute a value function through that
and then we compute level sets of those
and we use those to characterize this
reachable set so in this experiment here
what we've done is we've pre computed a
reachable set for this system we just
want it to follow a fairly simple step
trajectory in the lab we don't want it
to crash into the floor or fly into the
ceiling so it's basically an aerodynamic
flight envelope and we pre computed that
under a nominal model but then halfway
through the experiment we switched on so
it's just starting again now a large fan
which is introducing a disturbance in
the lower part of the room which is
going to affect the dynamics of the
quadrotor that disturbance is not
modelled and it wasn't taken into
account when we pre computed that
reachable set so what we're doing here
this is some of our first work in safe
learning and you kind of see you know
two experiments that are run
sequentially are superimposed similar
Oh sleaze with the kind of ghosted out
quadrotor that's being jutted around
that's what happens if you just keep
flying the quadrotor within that
precomputed reachable set the the other
quadrotor is using a safe learning
technique that we developed where when
the quadrotor which is measuring you
know its own behavior detects that it's
being buffeted around it shrinks the
reachable set to the point at which the
disturbances that it's measuring comply
with the safety certificate that is used
from the precomputed reachable set so it
shrinks the reachable set to a safe
region that complies with its current
measured values of that disturbance so
it's it's a technique that you know and
you can prove it safe under certain
assumptions of how the disturbance
enters the dynamics so the the wind
shift that's acting on that quadrotor is
buffeting it around a bit but it still
is
you know bounded and it's considered a
disturbance which is it still a
Lipschitz can be bounded with a
Lipschitz constant in the dynamics of
the system so there you know it works
for relatively mild disturbances it
doesn't work for example in the kinds of
problems that we're really thinking
about in this workshop or in navigation
problems where you know you're just
discovering things in the environment so
for example you've got a robot that's
navigating it knows where it wants to go
but it has no idea or you know it's got
very little idea of what the environment
around is going to be as it navigates
towards the goal and that's where we
really need to introduce and include
perception modules in the feedback
control loop are you convinced be
comforting them on the fly in in this
experiment we're not recomputing the
reachable that we pre computed a
reachable set and then we're shifting to
a different level set of that reachable
set so we're doing that in real time and
what I'm going to show you a little bit
later in the talk we're
computing the reachable set at each goal
other work that we've been doing and
this is another reason that we really
want to use perception in the loop has
you know unknown environments but also
you know people are very unknown so
autonomous systems that are navigating
around people and we've been doing a lot
of work jointly with angka dragons group
here at Berkeley to develop models which
allow us some sensible predictions of
how people are moving in different kind
of structured scenarios so for example
here we've got Silvia in my group who's
moving around there's a quadrotor these
are our smaller quad rotors they're
planning trajectories and they're
planning collision-free or
probabilistically collision free
trajectories based on a Bayesian update
that we're performing on the prediction
of how she's moving with some pre stated
goals and some understanding of how
she's moving between the goals so that's
just to give a little bit of an overview
but the the context here is dynamic
systems you know we care about safety
we're interested in learning safely but
now we're at this sort of open arena of
problems where the things we have to
learn are not characterized very well so
unknown environments people in the
environments and we want to be able to
try to either push our tools or develop
new tools which will allow us to use
kind of the best in perception but still
within a feedback loop and that's really
you know over the past two years as
we've been working on this so this is
Sami Obon Saul who's here in the group
who's here in the group and also here in
the talk has been developing this and
I'm gonna spend the first part of the
talk talking about kind of our lessons
learned in in doing this okay so the
first part of the talk we call
supervising learning using optimal
control so this is navigating in unknown
environments as an example but how might
we actually train a perception neural
net when we know something about optimal
control and we know how we'd want to
control this thing optimally if we if we
knew what the environment
and then after that I'm just going to
switch in the latter part of the talk to
how we integrate safety that kind of
reach ability to base safety that I
talked about already when it comes to
the vehicle dynamics so what I'm not
going to talk about today is I think and
this is why I said it's a little bit of
a shift or an anomaly given the rest of
the talks is the really important
problem of proving safety of the neural
net itself that you're actually getting
what you expect in your with a you know
your as you apply test data to that
neuron that you're not going to have the
kind of classifications that we've been
seeing in in some of the talks and
another point is that we're part of this
work as I'll say at the end is funded
where I'm running this DARPA contract
under the assured autonomy program and
we're also funded by the Navy in fact
that is here and here the problems are
really trying to look at you know real
autonomous systems aircraft and have
them navigate safely around other
aircraft or other obstacles for example
so we really care if it's classified as
an aircraft or a pig okay so let's um
let's go to the let's sort of start with
this first part of the talk and and
start with a motivational example so as
I said this is work that Samuel and
Varun have been leading it's jointly
with Jitendra Malik and Sarah Gupta in
jeetendra's group who graduated last
year from jeetendra's group and this is
the version of the paper that is
absolute so this is one of the robots in
our lab it's a turtle bot it has a
number of cameras on board but for the
purpose of these experiments we're just
going to use an RGB camera so the input
are one of the inputs to the system are
just pixel pixelized images so 224 by
224 images that we're getting over time
as this robot is moving through the
environment and and the setup is that it
it knows where it is it knows where it
wants to go in its own body coordinates
but it doesn't know the environment
around it
yeah well it's not a GPS but there's an
odometer onboard and so we're going to
assume for the purposes of this talk
that it knows it it has good
measurements of its own inertial z' and
you know we can that that's actually
something that's a fairly easily solved
problem so we can make that assumption
either indoors or outdoors now so in
terms of the in terms of this setup and
and you know the I think an interesting
question here and we've gone through
different iterations of architectures
but is is what kind of architecture that
we should be considering here what kinds
of architectures and as you'll see in
our comparisons there's been a lot of
work in the practical deep learning
community on end-to-end learning so that
basically means going from images all
the way down to control actions so your
the the neural net is learning that
pipeline from images to control actions
and and as a control theorist we have a
kind of intuition that part of that we
don't really need to learn we typically
know well the dynamics of the system
that we're controlling and also there's
been a huge amount of work done in
planning over the last decades so we can
really take advantage of a lot of this
planning and control work and just use
learning where it's needed and so the
the architecture that we're proposing
and the one that we've we've been
working on really for about the past
year of a two-year project is one in
which the neural network is taking in
images it's also as I said it's got its
own measurements of its own inertial z'
so it's also taking its own current
linear and angular velocities this is
the robot and information about its goal
position we're going to assume that's
given for now and it's going to as an
output rather than outputting control
actions it's just going to output a
waypoint a next Waypoint to go to and
we've got this in a loop so that there's
a time horizon
which is typically shorter than the time
it takes to go to the goal
so we'll you know basically be iterating
this over a number of time horizons
until it reaches or doesn't reach the
goal so the perception module rather
than going from image to control action
is going from image to Waypoint and then
we're developing the control pipeline or
the planning and control pipeline that
takes that Waypoint and gives you know a
plan and a set of sensible control
actions okay so I have a few things to
say about this architecture yes it does
know its current position so the the
robot model that we're using here is a
very simple model and we're assuming in
this case and I think this is a point
that we we've been discussing a lot is
what what should the representation of
that Waypoint be you know it should
comply with the model or the dynamics of
the system so it's if it's a very
complex walking robot maybe there are
more states that you want to include in
the Waypoint than just you know the XY
position and the current orientation but
it actually makes a big difference for
even this robot if you include just X Y
in the Waypoint or X Y Theta and so
there's a lot of trial and error that we
sort of went through to figure out what
works well but I think a very
interesting question is when we're
proposing an architecture where all of
the perception is then Clapp collapsed
into a waypoint and then the Waypoint
provides an input input to the control
architecture what really should the
representation of that Waypoint be you
know for different kinds of dynamics or
different kinds of tasks that you have
is the destination to reach for now
that's a good way to describe it it's
something that you're gonna start moving
towards and maybe you know it's also we
have this parameter H which represents
the horizon over which you're going to
apply the control that you generate to
reach that Waypoint but that may be
shorter than that may not be you know
you may not actually ever get to that
Waypoint depending on how you design the
waypoints and how you're designing so
what is the role of the neural network
part of this of this core system it's
see the screen shot and what is supposed
to do it's supposed to give you a
waypoint because like I guess there are
two three questions that are curious
like where where you are which you say
that is already solved so this is not a
problem what is in front of me can I
actually you know go for it or not yes
I'm actually set to and whether and
actually like what is your plan
regarding getting to the goal post so
where the last one is at rest so it's
the it's the second problem of your
three problems that we're focusing on
right so the first problem we've taken
away maybe it's an important problem but
is basically solved the third problem is
something that control theory has
treated for decades we don't need to
solve that problem and that's really my
point about model-based learning versus
end-to-end learning it's the middle
problem which is the hard problem that
control theorists have kind of ignored
and I think that's wrong and I think we
should be working together with people
doing learning and people doing
perception to come up with these
architectures
yeah yeah
well know it we don't use so we're using
supervision so we're using supervised
training but it's interesting to compare
this to reinforcement learning and so
I'm not gonna say it's reinforcement
learning but you could say pseudo and
I'll describe why okay so I want to say
a few more things about this before we
go on this architecture so as I said
there's a perception module there's a
plan of perception module a planning
module and a control module the planning
module again we went through different
iterations of what to do and we tried
out many different things in fact you
know maybe I can say this end-to-end
learning works really well and you know
as control theorists we were a little
bit surprised because we thought
immediately when we start introducing
model-based control instead of
end-to-end learning like when we say you
don't have to learn this just put models
put good planning algorithms in and do
it it became very challenging to
actually meet the same specs as
end-to-end learning and it took a long
time to be able to understand you know
and to tease out the differences so the
planning module that we have now that
we're now using here and by no means is
this the only thing we could do or not
you know maybe not even the best thing
we could do is a spline based planner
it's a simple planner the kind of thing
that's been used a lot we're using third
order splines partly that's because the
dynamics are fairly simple in fact for
those who know control this is a
differentially flat system so if you use
a third order spline then you're
basically capturing all the dynamics of
that vehicle so we're using you know if
you have position and speed and
acceleration characterized in your
spline you've basically characterized
the whole path of that dynamic system
which is of course a simplification of
the actual robot but it's a pretty good
model so that allows you when you're
doing the planning to come up with a set
of linear equations that you can solve
online the control we use a standard
we're just using an lqr control and it's
linearized so to get the linear and lqr
we're linearizing these dynamics around
the path around the spline based plan
that we've
computer so that's very standard in
control and as I said we tried out a
number of different architectures and
this is the one we're presenting now ok
so the training so this is the important
part the idea is that the really hard
thing is looking at an image and
recognizing where to go that's what the
neural net is going to do just to say a
little bit and I'll come back to this
we're using a convolutional neural net
we're using we tried out different
pre-trained architectures which is
standard now in computer vision we're
using a res net 50 architecture for the
neural net and and we as I said you know
sort of earlier in the talk we're using
we're supervising the learning using
optimal control so let me tell you a
little bit about what that means
and I'll talk about how we train the
neural net to sort of describe that so
so sort of physically for this
navigation problem we used to train the
neural net a set of databases that
Stanford provides it's this 3d Stanford
3d indoor spaces they've they've built
up a number of textured environments of
a number of their buildings at Stanford
and these are it's a database that
everybody has access to so we use two of
those indoor spaces to train the neural
net and then we held out one of the
spaces as a test set the in general when
you're running this the location and
shape of the obstacles is unknown but in
training we're going to assume that so
for training we assume that we know the
location of the obstacles and the shape
of the obstacles and we develop a cost
function so in optimal control the cost
function here is the distance to the
obstacles so we know where we are in
terms of the robot distance to obstacles
we want to avoid those and the distance
to the goal we know where the goal is so
we've got you know we're trying to go
towards the goal and avoid the obstacles
so we're just using a very standard cost
function for the optimal control problem
and then the optimal control problem is
to find a waypoint
which minimizes this cost
we use we're using a Euclidean distance
and and and likewise we're avoiding so
we're trying to get to the goal and
we're trying to avoid the obstacles but
it's well it's trying to essentially
yeah but you can wait the you know you
can choose the waiting on the goal
versus the obstacles so and I'll say a
little bit about that but when you don't
wait the obstacles enough then as
optimal control tends to do it will try
to like you know skirt corners to be
able to get to the goal that's not such
a great thing to do when you're training
a neural net because then it tends the
actual thing tends to bump into the
corners a lot so so yeah but essentially
we're we're using a very simple cost
this summary is beyond which you don't
care well yeah I mean the you just
physically the radius of the robot
itself yeah and so we could do something
a little bit more complex and maybe this
is what you're asking that we just you
know we don't the obstacle isn't gonna
have any effect on us if we're far
enough away but right now that's we're
using something simpler than that to
evaluate this so we're comparing this
with end to end learning because as I
said that's kind of our goal to be able
to see if we can do better because
intuitively that's what we expect we
also trained a similar neural net for
but to go all the way from images to
control actions so we we trained a
ResNet 50 for end-to-end learning and
that was trained using instead of using
waypoints we use the smooth control
commands that are generated from this
architecture so we have two neural nets
one is the one we're developing and one
is for comparison and then overall when
we use that optimal control so we use
that optimal control for training when
we use it to train the neural net we're
using an MSE loss as a as an objective
function which is on the Waypoint
position so this is what
the expert would give four Waypoint this
is what the neuron that would give for a
waypoint and that's our loss function
and then the case of end to end it's
just the control what's the difference
between the two controls okay so that's
what I wanted to say about training and
and so now we take that so now we don't
know where the obstacles are we're just
putting this robot in an environment
knows where it is again it knows we're
using the body frame coordinates so it
knows where it is in its body frame
knows where the goal is in its body
frame has you know its inertial z'
and it takes an image and it has to
figure out what to do so in the training
examples
you're still generating the waypoints so
you know the environment because we have
the database you know where the
obstacles are and you generate your
waypoints and then so so that's what's
that's the that's the data that's used
in training well we get waypoints using
our methodology but it's using our
methodology with known environments and
known locations of obstacles
three dimensionally they do but this is
they also have textured meshes and we're
using textured meshes yeah that's a good
question
so a number of waypoints may I mean
we're we're solving this optimal control
problem but we're also constrained by
the you know the the waypoints that we
can generate so we select I mean we may
come up with several waypoints that are
good and we you know we select one of
those that is conflict free however
where I have a point to say about at the
end about that after we talk about reach
ability you know we may actually be able
to use safe learning in the context of
training this neural net alright so so
this is this is a comparison with end to
end so ours is the red model based and
gray is end to end so we're getting
about if you look at the top plot about
a 25 percent improvement in success of
reaching the goal than end to end
learning and then if you take those
successful runs so just the ones that
are successful for both end to end and
our model based these are the kinds of
comparisons so less time to reach the
goal average acceleration along the
trajectory lower average jerk along the
trajectory significantly lower and so
this is starting to see what we would
expect from control theory like if
you're you're including a model I mean
that's the the dynamic so you're gonna
get smoother trajectories your going to
do things that adhere to the dynamics of
the system more so here there are a few
plots just for a couple of different
tasks where you know you've got starting
out position and the green as the goal
position and just the comparisons with
what the method our method does model
based versus end to end and so you see
this sort of difficulty for example in
turning sharp corners with end to end or
doing things that require you
like a sharp decision once it gets that
image of you know something in front of
it and as you might expect the control
pop profile for end-to-end is much
smoother so you see you know less jerks
less kind of you know changes sharp
changes in velocity in the red than you
do in the ring I'm sorry just here my
minions what exactly is the way you
captured the distance of the obstacle in
my pocket I think it's just the
Euclidean distance
so euclidean distance to goal and then a
negative weight on Euclidean distance to
obstacle and so I wonder about is if you
have settings where that doesn't truly
tell you not to crash or something like
you sort of I guess what fund against
something like think just get like that
scale of your penalty should go up like
dramatically as you approach the
obstacle I got my anything a situation
where I would like have two obstacles
and like some of the Euclidean distances
would be the same now it's not like
fundamentally misunderstand something
right I just want to understand like I
guess I'm saying is I can I have two
obstacles and if I'm looking into some
of Euclidean distances and being right
next to one of them are right next to
the other one is just as good as being
in the midpoint whereas if I said the
closer you get the scale is going to go
up like super linearly did not push me
so I wonder no that's a good question
and I should say we did so we've tried
out different costs so assigned distance
Euclidean distance with coefficients
yeah so but we could mimic that with
like the like the relative weights on
those individual cost functions so we
can you know scale the importance of
avoiding obstacles versus going for the
Gophers then the waste can whatever the
weight is on avoiding obstacles is the
saying this is how do I feel about being
in the middle verse it's a good question
and these these are questions that come
up in you know planning and control
anyway but you've still typically got
your your weight that's pulling you
towards your goal in that case so you're
you know there's typically something to
break the asymmetry but in a perfectly
symmetric case you might run into some
of that again ya know it's true but it
depends on the the weights the relative
weights so these issues can come up and
those are issues that exist in you know
planning and control anyway you said you
failed in 18 percent of the events you
know why I'll show you some of the
failures but that's a good question
we're typically failing in places you
know some of them we just don't know and
that's actually you know it's something
that I'm interested with why I'm
attending this workshop a lot of it is
here's one example we're we're training
typically so we're using a held out data
set from Stanford for test and then I'll
show you some test results of where we
just took that same architecture did no
other training so it's just trained in
simulation and we applied it on a real
robot here at Berkeley so typically
you'll see that the failures occur when
you see you know chairs that are a
little bit different than the ones that
you trained on so you know for example
in the held-out test set they have
different shaped chairs with some metal
bases that swirl where you don't see
those so much in the trained set so
those are the kinds of things they're
perception largely perception errors
where the thing just gets too close to
the obstacle because it's not
recognizing that it's an obstacle I just
want to say very quickly that not only
did we compare this with an end-to-end
learning scheme we compared it with you
know the traditional pipeline envision
and control which is slam and that's
very important to do I mean this is a
typical slam based scenario but here you
know and I think this is an important
point for learning is that and and why
computer vision has basically adopted
deep learning as opposed to these more
traditional pipelines is that the you
know the the sensor failure in slam is
one of the biggest reasons that slam
fails in a lot of cases and this just
shows you know the RGB image and you
know what a typical depth sensor so
we're running a fairly recent slam
algorithm here to do the comparisons and
you know in all of these cases these are
cases where the black indicates where
the you know the depth is not known it's
typically around an obstacle so failures
and it's not just things like this it
smudges on the camera we work a bit with
sky do which is that company that's
designing basically a flying camera that
tracks you as you're doing sports events
and you know if you touch the lens you
get a little smudge on the lens
immediately slam algorithms start to
fail where the learning algorithms don't
and so you can see the kinds of
comparisons of the model-based scheme
versus well this is end to end but even
a traditional slam pipeline and very
much over a memoryless slam pipeline it
should be stated that you know our
method is memoryless so it seemed like a
good comparison to do just let me show
you some of the simulation results
an exhaustive interim learning would it
reach the same level of performance and
that's a good question
I yes because the failures are in cases
where you know that they're their
failures which appear to be at that
intersection of perception and control
however the amount of data that you
would need to train I believe will be
much more than a model based scheme so I
think the sample efficiency of one of
the reasons to use a model based scheme
is that intuitively you should do less
training and that's what we're seeing
here where we're doing an apples to
apples comparison and as much as we can
in terms of the training data used in
you know we used exactly the same
training data in all of these
comparisons really good question so if
the test time so we're assuming a model
here for this turtle bot which is pretty
good you know it's a four dimensional
dynamic model we're trying this now so
Koelsch rena who's in our Emmie
department and works on walking robots
is really interested in applying this to
his walking robot with a camera on board
and we're asking you know what so should
we be changing the Waypoint or is a
position and an orientation kind of a
good encapsulation of anything for a
navigation problem I I don't know I
think that the Waypoint has to be
somehow it has to it has to capture
something rich enough about the dynamics
but ideally be simple enough so that
this this algorithm and architecture can
be transferred from you know one robot
to another and one task to another but
obviously if your tasks involve you know
a robot that's going to the kitchen it's
got an arm it's got to do some you know
can I thought of a drawer the waypoints
have to be more rich in terms of the
task itself so for navigation perhaps
this is a good way point to use I don't
know I this is something that we're
exploring now for more richer tasks
because it's obviously not going to be
enough that's a really really good
question we it seems to matter although
you know it's a neural net so again we
don't know it seems to matter whether
it's a bike or a chair but does it
matter you know does it in terms of it
recognizing because in some way we're
just training it to recognize
automatically that it's got to avoid
these things but it shouldn't really and
so we've been doing experiments now
where we're holding out parts of the
image and asking you know what is the
importance of relative parts of the
image it's very experimental so it's I
don't know I think it's an excellent
question
yeah I totally agree with you sorry from
that from the picture over there it
seems like you're using that camera you
know it is a it is a stereo it is an RGB
D camera but we're just using the RGB
image yes I mean we compared it with
slam where we did use the D / slam so
we're you know in that comparison but
for this architecture we're just using
RGB no classical object recognition at
all alright let me just run this so I've
got a couple of experiments to show you
so you know this is what the robot sees
so these are just for your own benefit
the robot doesn't see these but you can
see you know so it's asked to go from
this point which it knows to a goal
which it knows and it it doesn't know
what's in between it's got a hallway
with some bikes it's got some chairs
that it has to go around to be able to
get to the goal so you can see you know
I think what's nice and we noticed
immediately when you compare with end to
end is the smoothness of the control
profile as opposed to the kind of
jerkiness you see in the end-to-end
learning approaches here's one which I
like to include because it shows
something about a little bit towards
semantic understanding so it has to go
out of the lab and into the hallway and
to do that it has to recognize that it
has to go through a door we never
trained it to go through well I mean we
it was implicitly trained to go through
doors using the the architecture that we
developed when it comes into the hallway
all immediately it's in a very shiny
floor with a lot of sunlight that
doesn't AB that wood that kills the slam
but that does well here it doesn't even
care about the shininess of the floor
and you know we don't the environments
are static in this set of experiments
but we tried the same architecture on a
somewhat dynamic environment so here is
Varun one of our one of the lead authors
on this who is just moving the chair
around based on you know where the
robots going to get towards it's cool so
we're not saying we're working on
dynamic environments but you know you
can see a little bit of a start towards
a generalization and dynamic
environments is actually what we're
working on now yeah I mean it's smooth
because it's using control so it makes
sense so finally we got some results
that seem to make sense with what we
would sort of Intuit let me just talk
about some lessons learned I'm you know
I started a bit late but I don't want to
go too far so I do have a second part of
this talk on control I'm probably gonna
skip that I think just because I think
this is actually the point that I wanted
to get across some of these I've already
said so data representation is important
whether we use an inertial view or
whether we use a body view you know how
we represent the the it's ego
coordinates and how we represent the
goal it's it appears to be much more
efficient to use an ego centric
representation and that's actually quite
interesting from a planning point of
view we have a parallel project that I'm
not talking about here with Jack gallant
in cognitive psychology who works on how
people he he he puts F nears caps over
people in simulation car driving
environments and he asks you know what
are the features that are important when
people are planning and so this is um
this is something that we're now trying
to understand can we take some of these
ideas to use them in autonomous system
and as I said before optimal control can
be to optimal again you know this all
depends on the cost function we're using
and we talked a little bit about that
but you know it tends optimal control if
it can it will tend to or it depends on
how you set up the cost function but you
know if you set it up so that it skirts
corners just that's typically not a good
idea if you're using it in supervised
training of such a neural net the
Waypoint representation is important
position versus position and orientation
it was actually a very big deal in in
achieving success here to use
orientation and I think a lot of you
know this because your neural net people
but but we you know I'm a control
theorist so building on existing neural
net architectures was very important the
computer vision community has has a
whole set of pre trained neural nets
that they use and that have been
optimized and there's a lot of tools and
methods that have been developed over
time that work really well so working
with Jitendra group was really important
here to understand or maybe not
understand but but sort of get the idea
about good starting points and what we
should do it's very important this makes
sense it's very important to consider
image and prospective distortions during
training so don't just use the actual
you know data but distort it and so
that's something that we understand from
control and this comes back to the
reinforcement learning point we're not
using reinforcement learning here but in
a sense you could consider this whole
architecture doing you know
reinforcement learning when we we
thought that once we had this
architecture we could improve on it by
just applying reinforcement learning and
it got worse and you know the this is
something that we're now exploring in
more detail it's not clear why we you
know again this is empirical but our L
on supervised learning at this point
seems appears to be worse than just the
RL architecture I showed when you say
improve on it is a reinforcement
learning
so as much as like how is this system
set up it's a whole architecture the
entire pipeline set up such that you
could have what would be say like a need
reinforcement learning system that is
initialized and truly having the exact
same I'd like this sort of case where
you would think you could strictly
improve would be when your RL system
could be initialized to be doing like
exactly what you're doing that's that's
a good point but we I mean this
architecture I mean we talked a lot
about it but it's fairly generic and you
know we're allowing the system to start
off in any initial condition different
configurations and it's a fairly simple
problem just reach a goal through a
number of waypoints I would put multiple
waypoints and then you have this
procedure for choosing one yeah like the
our else is the freaking deep reinforced
lines like the only at least I'm
probably nothing behind the times but
it's the two ways I know it's happening
that it's like there have a value
function and then your policy is given
by like choosing what you think is going
to be the action that's been you the
high skew value or heist expected to
valid or more common when you start off
with some kind of behavior cloning or
something your your model set up as a
continuous function whose outputs are
you know interpreted as a probability
distribution over your possible actions
I said what I wonder is just because it
seems like there are some components of
the decision process that weren't like
you know like you guys in like in some
like natural language stuff or whatever
where someone initializes a model that
is trained as a supervised model so
they're doing like some behavior cloning
and it's natural to strictly improve on
it with RL because you say okay the
model is already this continuous path
thing you guys feel like giving me
probabilities at the end and so I
applied that's an egg quality gradient
on top of that I guess we're just
wondering is like how you get the
starting point for the RL given that the
pipeline I wish I don't fully understand
all the details it's I'm not protecting
that I may be it is a great clear
insights
yeah I think that maybe to answer your
question so we're using when we apply
reinforcement learning on top of this
we're using the same kind of structure
the same kind of cost function but what
you're saying is unless you're
specifically at that particular point
and you're you're looking at that
particular trace and you you look at
what the values of the cost function are
maybe what you're doing in reinforcement
learning is not going to measure it with
you know what you attained already using
the supervised learning procedure and
that's true I don't know it's something
that we've just we looked at you know
and in no deep way yet so as I said I
have a secondary point and I think I'm
just gonna use this question yes in fact
that's something that since we completed
this stage of the work we've been
spending more time on incorporating
visual memory into this and and that's I
would say it's ongoing I'm not sure how
well I'm not sure how much improvement
we're going to get using visual it's
clear we'll get some improvement in fact
one of our co-authors are a Gupta in
Jitendra Malik's group has worked on a
visual memory pipeline and that's the
algorithm that we're incorporating I
think it's going to improve it a little
bit it's not clear that it's going to be
you know groundbreaking in terms of
improving but that's that's a good
question so just to conclude some of the
and it comes back to this question what
are the cases in which it fails those 18
percent so here's a case where you know
the chair here so this is again we took
the simular results from training and
simulation and no real experiments in
training and we just applied it in a
real environment as you saw in the
previous movies but here's a case of
failure so you know these chairs with
it's got some kind of back but then the
bottom stick out of it those don't exist
at Stanford
train dips down for trying it at
Berkeley different environments it fails
so it's it's kind of what you would
expect I'm gonna not go into detail
about the later part of the talk but I'm
gonna skip to the to the end just to say
that what we've been doing now is taking
that same architecture that I presented
and incorporating what we call kind of a
safety filter or a safety verifier but
importantly it's not on the neural
network that's the hard problem that
this workshop is focusing on we've
basically computed using a depth map and
computing an occupancy map so basically
using a traditional slam pipeline to
compute reachable sets like I discussed
at the very beginning of the talk and
use those for safety verifiers so if
it's going to approach the bottom of
that chair and it looks like it's
getting close the reachable set control
is going to push it away from that so it
has a better chance of reaching the goal
and so that's that's part of our current
work so let me conclude by just saying
that the the goal here and the goal of
this line of work is to think about you
know sensible reasonable good
architectures for incorporating
perception into the control loop we
discussed a method for using supervised
learning trained using optimal control
so it provides this perception planning
and control pipeline where these are
model-based and this is trained using
all
so the neural net is just here we
compared it both with slam as well as to
end-to-end learning and applied it to
this vision based navigation class and
then in later work we've been using
real-time updates of this safe set so
that that computation we're now doing in
real time taking advantage of warm
starting and local updates to compute
that hamilton-jacobi filter in real time
and so to conclude I just like to thank
the members of my group as well as
jeetendra's group who worked on this as
I said it's led by Samuel Bonsall who's
here today and funding primarily through
DARPA in fact behzod had a grant years
ago that we Amiri that with MIT so it
was Daniella ruse and me and Jitendra
and others where we really had the kind
of foundations of this work there and
other folks so thank you very much
[Applause]